four horrible radical left Democrat
investigations by the way I I know
people seeing this are going to write to
me and say David how can you not comment
on the fact that it's not even orange
that Trump is anymore it's almost like
he he's he's painted himself so dark
that it doesn't even make any sense and
his lips look white and folks I get it I
get it but it's not the focus here I get
that he looks like a like a reverse mime
I guess we would say but we're not
focusing on that here
your all-time favorite President me
is just a continuation of the most
disgusting Witch Hunt in the history of
our country it's gone on forever with
Russia Russia Russia and Ukraine Ukraine
Ukraine and all our hooks it's an
absolute disgrace what's going on they
even spied on my campaign of course
that's not true
[Music]